course today is Memorial Day in Boulder
City preparations for the 31st Annual
Memorial Day Services they are underway
right now thousands are expected to
attend the service at the southern
Nevada Veterans Memorial Cemetery
Candace Charles joins us live this
morning here in the studio with how you
can take part Candace good morning good
morning too well all happens at 1pm at a
very special place the Southern Nevada
Veteran Memorial Cemetery in Boulder
City the only official veterans cemetery
in southern Nevada each year thousands
come here on Memorial Day to honor those
who lost their lives in the line of duty
and that's really what it's all about
there have been events leading up to
this all week on Thursday there was a
service for unaccompanied veterans this
cemetery is a place to come remember and
celebrate those who gave so much the
ultimate sacrifice for our freedom
it's a nice quiet spot to remember all
our members that have served in the
military all branches all eras
now remember that service starts at one
you can expect some traffic and to take
some time to look for parking so arrive
early if you can now if you can't make
it put down the hot dog and corn and
take a moment at 3 pm today to silently
remember those who lost their lives
fighting for our country we're now live
in the studio I'm Candace Charles 8 news
now absolutely Candace got to remember
why the day is the day it says 6 35
other events happening across Southern
Nevada for Memorial Day the Lakes is
hosting its 21st annual ceremony at nine
this morning in about three hours or so
if you're interested register ahead of
time va.gov Henderson's annual field of
Honor ceremony that also starts at nine
o'clock over at Cornerstone Park